[Music]
all right good morning everyone my name
is Zoltan urato I'm a product manager of
Google Cloud IOT let me also introduce
my co-presenters for today kerima let's
give and Lucho Diaw CEO both from
microchip all right IOT security solving
the primary hurdle to IOT deployment in
this breakout session we are going to
show you evidence why connected product
companies and IOT fleet operators find
security or top hurdle a top challenge
we will also talk about how and why
these challenges ultimately come down to
a question of of cost and complexity and
most importantly we will show you a tool
set or give you a tool set an end-to-end
toolset that can help you solving these
challenges so let's take a look at our
agenda first very quickly we will touch
upon the why why the need is undeniable
why it's a top concern then we are going
to talk about the theory like the
principles of solving IOT security and
and probably the longest part of the
presentation is about the solution
proposed by Google and microchip so
let's start by this number this is a an
actual Gartner number so this is not an
estimation and this is from last year
number of connected devices so it's
probably more now I guess all of you
remember those estimations from few
years back predicting super high numbers
of connected devices now this is real
this is happening our device is
generating more data than ever and that
also means that the attack surface is
growing rapidly and important to
highlight that these devices are most of
the time resource constrained and
acuity measurements are close to
non-existent many times and there is a
video evidence to death so we see a
clear acceleration of attacks probably
the most well-known is Mirai I'm sure
many of you have heard about Mirai it it
was a botnet a botnet attack two years
ago it hit low low secured camera CCTVs
cameras and performed a DDoS attack
against Dean
one of the biggest domain name services
in the US and brought the internet down
or most of the internet down for
multiple hours just another example
which happened this year a hacker got
into a casino using a thermostat of a
fish tank
so not only DDoS attacks are are a
threat to in in relation to IOT
deployments but also these devices are
connected to your network so they can
access their network so if a hacker can
go to get to your device they can go
into your network what this really means
to us is that IOT security is complex
it's challenging it takes time to to
secure an IOT deployment and it's not
something you can do once your fleet is
deployed it cannot be an afterthought
you really need to take care of security
before you deploy devices so let's take
a look at the challenges of IOT security
this is just a summary we are going to
more we are going more into the details
very soon so strong device identity and
authentication how you identify our
devices I authenticate them how you use
a symmetric keys for these securing the
manufacturing line high transfer keys
it's a complex process how you protect
your keys and how you make sure that the
software ran by your device is what it
is supposed to run and key rotation how
to treat keys as a femoral and how to
update keys as needed and of course
application layer security it's very
important but we are not going to talk
about application layer security we are
going to focus on the IOT related parts
it's not that it's not easy or it's not
that it's easy but it's much more well
described or discussed so we are not
going to talk about that here even
though most of these principles can be
implemented using software only a much
higher level of security can be achieved
if we involved specialized Hardware so
that's why hardware plays a key role in
secure IOT deployments and that's also
why we partnered with microchip because
there they're offering place key a key
part in in in in what we offer as a
secure solution for end-to-end
deployments so I would like to invite
Carrie on stage who will talk more about
microchip I don't know how many of you
are familiar with microchip we've been
around for 30 years and we ship over 2
billion 8-bit MCS every year so maybe
many of you out there I've designed some
kind of system with a pic or an AVR
microcontroller and you're familiar with
microchip you may or may not be familiar
with the broader range of products the
microchip has among them things like
wireless and wired connectivity
solutions and analog devices interface
chips and security devices so so well
and all that kind of kind of gives us
this idea of having devices that are
smart like an MCU
did wireless which is really what IOT is
all about and secure which we're going
to make the case here is a key part of
how you build an IOT endpoint thinking
about security at a hardware level and
obviously microchip has a good solution
across that board so let me just start
and kind of reiterate some of the points
that salt handmade it's hard to
overestimate the importance of a device
identity right when you get past all the
three and four letter acronyms you get
all the words everybody's all happy
about what they got in security you have
an identity and an endpoint it's a
number it's really all it is right
there's a number it's a digital world if
that number gets compromised hmm then
you don't have a secure endpoint doesn't
matter what protocol you use doesn't
matter what algorithm use if I can copy
your number your device ID your key what
if you want to call it and I am you
alright
so so everything we're gonna think about
is going to be how do we take that
ultimate route or trust that a device
key and protect that in a way that then
we can build upon that to build a secure
system and so to do that you need a
couple things you need to be able to
verify that identity and obviously if I
just send you my identity I send over
the network
I'm carry what everybody knows that
right you can look at it up so that's
not a really a very good idea it needs
to be something that can be verified
without being disclosed trust a bull
unique obviously it's no good if there's
a lot of carries out there and there
probably are so there must be something
different about me than the others
we'll talk about that this isn't talk
about cryptography but let's just say
that asymmetric cryptography is a good
solution for this approach maybe we will
store private key as an identity we'll
use the public key as a way to validate
that I won't talk too much about how the
mechanics of it work but you'll see how
that plays out as we go forward here
it's okay we got this this number this
digital ID this private key what I'm
going to call it I said that's what
everything is about that's what's
important
well how do you get it in your gadget
right how do you put that private key
into your device in such a way that well
ideally not too many devices have copy
of the same private key when you mess up
you know you've got a diverse
manufacturing environment subcontractors
on three continents maybe one guy built
one part of the system other guys built
another part of the system maybe next
year you have a different subcontinent
you got this year how do you manage that
environment in such a way that the way
these identities go in your device can
really be trusted they're all unique so
this is a pretty complicated problem and
let me propose a solution that says I
don't care where you manufacture let's
move that identity process that identity
assignment process out of the
manufacturing sub cons into the supplier
of the semiconductor so you build to
take a secure element secure chip same
thing and the manufacturer of the
security up in this case microchip we
program that identity in it so when it
shows up at the menu at the
manufacturing sites and your
subcontractors it's already got that
identity and let's go one step further
than that
let's build not only the identity but
the relationship between that identity
and something else that relationship
might be manifested in the certificate
that's a traditional PKI scheme it might
be manifested in some kind of a
registration scheme that's what we'll
talk about it a little bit later in the
presentation but so identity and a
relationship pre built into that chip so
no matter where you build it in the
world you get that same trust of its
unique nobody was watching when you put
it in the device okay so so we got any
identity we got a way to get it in your
gadget but wait a minute
then the gadgets going to go out in the
field there's going to be Gillian's of
these things right you guys are all big
successful companies you sell millions
and millions and billions of devices and
everywhere around the world is going to
be your device and because you're so
successful a lot of people are going to
want to try copy your device and if they
want to copy your device they need to
get that digital ID out of one of them
and then they make 50 copies of that one
or maybe get out of a hundred so you
really don't want them taking the
digital ID out of your device and you're
going to protect against that one way
you do that or maybe the only way to do
that is to provide some kind of secure
storage for that private key that secret
and let's just say that you really don't
want anybody didn't mess with it they
can't
pietà can't change it they can't delete
it any of those things are really bad
once that happens then the device really
doesn't have a connection anymore to the
network right so that's good but it's
not enough you got to protect what your
device does I got the temperature sensor
or I've identified that it's in room 12
but if I can change the software well
yeah I'm talking to the thing in room 12
but no it's not really giving me the
temperature it's giving me a bogus
number right so you got to protect the
firmware there's lots ways to do that
let's just say one fairly traditional
way is to verify a signature over that
code every time the thing boots right so
it's hard to change the software you
know I could like replace the chip
without getting the thing to reboot so
let's verify code signature of boot a
lot of people call that secure boot that
seems like a good answer we'll connect
that a little bit later to hardware
security now sell tell made a mention
about key rotation and you know you
might say to me whoa whoa you just said
you're gonna store this thing really
super secure nobody's gonna be able to
touch it why do I need to rotate it hey
nobody can nobody can mess with it well
there could be sort of rules regulations
policies that demand it that's okay
right we all got rules we've got to
follow sometimes they don't make any
sense that's just life so it could be
policies there could be limits every
algorithm has a limit on the number of
times it can be used before the key is
no longer considered to be valid so
that's okay I don't mind that but so so
you want to be able to do this rotation
but at the same time you can't think
that rotation is a substitute for
security right if if I say well I don't
need to secure the key store Lee because
next week I'm gonna have a new key so
who cares it's only one week that isn't
gonna work right because the bad guys
are gonna find it not next week not next
day they're gonna find it three seconds
after you rotate that key and if you
don't have a way to protect that key for
that week that year that month that ten
million transactions then you still
don't have security so so key rotation
is important got to do it but it's no
substitute for sort of an environment in
which you didn't have to do it so so
think about that there's lots of ways to
do that I'm not going to talk about it
too much PKI or asymmetric cryptography
gives you a couple of ways you can
either generate new keys and sign them
with a trusted key you can use a
derivation mechanism there are lots out
there that are good you could store
multiple keys in your device you could
ship it with 10 keys and we could say
I'm gonna use the keys that ran or it's
got a 10-year life cycling when you use
the first key for the first year and the
second key for the second year however
you want to do it that's fine it's all
good and the cloud is gonna manage those
policies right so the cloud understands
the trust relationship the cloud
understands the architecture of the
device and the cloud can say ok hey I
don't like that key anymore let's go on
to the next key right so that's a good
thing about having the cloud
relationship no longer does the device
have to be able to say hey I don't like
this key anymore now the cloud can
manage that so you know Sultan touched
on this you know you build your system
you got all kinds of software you love
all your software solutions you got this
stack you got that stack maybe you down
a little some software but at the end of
the day there's that that thing that I
started with that digital ID right it's
got to be used you got to like put it as
input to some complicated algorithm and
that means your software it's got to
touch that so there's a piece of
software that has access to that digital
ID that private key well so if one piece
of software can touch it how you gonna
prevent other pieces of software from
touching and all you gotta know s you
have kernel code yeah sure we all know
all kinds of exploits which allow things
that you wish wouldn't touch stuff to
actually touch them so especially in the
IOT world where you know you've got
these complicated things you're all
these stats doing all these different
things but your temperature sensor right
what's the temperature in room 12 but
it's really complicated to do that right
so we're gonna propose here is I'm gonna
isolate those private keys from all of
the software would say no software could
touch the private keys I don't care what
software you have good bad big small
purple green doesn't touch the private
key and by doing that it leaves a lot of
questions a lot of problems you have to
validate takes those away right
and by the way it's not that we don't
like users it's not that we don't trust
them it's that they make poor choices
right okay how many of us have ever
logged on and created a password that
may not have been an optimal password
right once or twice it happens right so
you can't really trust users it doesn't
mean they're bad people it doesn't mean
they're untrustworthy it just means that
they make choices that may not be
consistent with security so not going to
users see it not glad it's software see
it and you know we talk about hardware
you might think oh I got a
microprocessor that's piece of hardware
right now I'm not really micro
processors are typically not designed to
protect keys in a way that an aggressive
attack might get them and I'll show you
in a minute what an aggressive attack
means and if you think about it you
connect all these dots now that means
that it's also protected in the
manufacturing phase right because even
their manufacturer doesn't have an ax
way to attack it right so you've got
some sub con cider and chips on the
board it doesn't matter he could be just
as untrusted as some guy out in the
field who hacked the sensor off the wall
of room 12
right so totally protected during the
manufacturing phase so okay that's a
nice these are all nice concepts now how
do we build that into something that's
useful that we can ship to customers
that connect to the cloud and do a
useful thing it's gotta have value right
so first thing used to secure chip so
I'm going to talk a little bit here
about the eighty ECC 608 a so I won't
say that too much you know think of it
as a secure element okay it's a secure
chip think of it as an electronic safe
what's it gonna do it's gonna do of
course it's gonna store that digital ID
right it's got some secure W Prime it's
gonna put the key in there it's just a
key rights just a number it's gonna
store that there and it's gonna include
enough crypto engines on it so we can
act on that key without having to
divulge the key wouldn't be very
interesting if I had to send the key out
right the key never ever leaves the chip
you want to do an authorization you want
to do some kind of validation you say
okay hey prove that you have that secret
without divulging the secret
and so all of that's done inside this
boundary so there's a hardware boundary
you try and get through the boundary as
an attacker and you can't all right so
it's all encapsulated it's no software
inside it's not something where you
write the code and maybe there's some
bugs in the code right it's all a
turnkey solution and I'll just point out
the red box over there I like to point
this out because everybody thinks well
random numbers you know I don't know
just get some keystrokes doesn't matter
right well I mean actually every single
cryptographic protocol out there one way
or the other requires random numbers and
random numbers are really hard to
generate so my favorite definition of a
random number one that's never been
generated before and will never be
generated again right that's a random
number it's it's maybe not a technical
description but it's not a bad
functional description and it's really
hard to do that in a way that you can
trust right everybody's got their multi
gigahertz multi-core processor think how
many times you can try different numbers
so if you want a number that's different
this time than last time it had better
be really good and it's really hard to
do that so I'm gonna put all those
things inside this box and I'm just have
a simple interface to it right I squared
see one wire so easy to talk to but hard
to get inside so that's the kind of
basic concept concept of a secure
element okay I got this what good is it
because it's all by itself right that's
not the temperature sensor in room 12
that's just a little box with a device
ID in it how you gonna use it well
you're gonna connect it to whatever
you've got on your system so you've got
some kind of processing element maybe
it's the edge TPU that just got
announced maybe it's on MCU an MP you
and that guy is gonna talk to it now the
slide here you know show something like
we're the MCU passes a challenge to the
chip the chip responds with a response
and the MCU has some way of verifying
that that's a financer well we're
actually going to show later in the
presentation in the demo is the cloud
sending a challenge down through the
microprocessor to the chip the chip
responds sends that response back
through the microprocessor up to the
cloud and then cloud decides whether
it's
to accept this transaction this
relationship or not right so I said at
the beginning that asymmetric
cryptography and private keys make a
nice way to think about a device ID I
stand by that it's beautiful but there
are downsides to PKI and some people
like symmetric or shared identification
as well I'm totally cool with that
that's a good idea there's a time and a
place for that
so that challenge and response it could
be a challenge in a signature if it's
asymmetric it could be a challenge in a
Mac if it's symmetric
that's a perfectly valid things and I
would never say that one is more secure
than the other one maybe more
appropriate than the other but they're
both secure ways to accomplish this
problem of verifiable identification
right and then let me just make a small
point for those of you out there who
have designed pc boards and alike this
is tiny little thing right it's it's
it's not your video processor with 300
iOS it's a tiny little box with a couple
of wires for i/o and when look Joe this
is demonstration you'll see it's
probably the smallest chip on the board
even though it has the most security of
all those chips on the board so okay
we're gonna think about this secure
element now it fits
whatever your endpoint looks like I
don't care whether it's got a 32-bit
64-bit eight core processor or it's an
8-bit single-threaded machine with K
bytes of memory doesn't matter and
everything in between
you could put this on that board and now
you've got a route of trust that you can
trust separate from all your software
from all the other pieces of your system
so keep protection you know great I'm up
here I'm selling this thing I say hey
it's really strong two keys trust me
right well maybe you don't so how is it
that people get these keys out right I
mean lots of software attacks salt and
slide showed a bunch of different
software attacks but you know if you're
making a billion gadgets you got a lot
somebody else would like to steal your
market right 10% or 1% of your billion
gadget market is a big number I'd really
like to have that as a bad guy and so
I'm not gonna stop at some published
attack right I'm gonna do all sorts of
crazy things like this particular crazy
thing I got up there is a micro prober
you know you could scrape the top off
the chip you can put some needles down
on the chip and trust me this is not a
complicated thing you can buy micro
Provos on eBay you can use them in your
kitchen it doesn't really require
anything too complicated it's really use
kind of probe down you know that JTAG
lock that you got on your processor you
hit that bit and no more JTAG right
unless I put a micro probe down on that
JTAG wire and I pull it high and say oh
now I do have jtag and I reuse jtech to
read the key out right so ah
so if you get a secure element there's
some picture of it's sort of a piece and
a blow-up of a piece of that you know
secure elements typically will have a
shield so that serpentine thing on the
side covers the entire chip there's
nothing to look at and then why the
signals that are going through that if
nothing to do with cryptographic or
identity they're just random signals
that we check and if you short them out
or cut them then ship stops working and
it's dead but look I'm only showing this
particular attack because it really
looks good on a slide whereas pictures
shield stuff like that there are way
better attacks than this one this was
complicated you know probably people are
gonna notice if you kind of take your
thing apart and strip the silicon off
you know my favorite sort of non non
visible attack is some kind of a side
channel attack you put a resistor in
series with the battery you do a single
trace or maybe multiple traces of the
power signature during a cryptographic
operation you take that trace away you
put the battery cover back on hang the
thing back on the wall and now at your
leisure you analyze that trace and using
that analysis you can find the key and
so if you think that anybody's
microprocessor won't leak data when it's
executing code this isn't the right
slide presentation but I got some really
good ones to show you how it's done it's
actually not that hard so there are
hundreds of different attacks and you
have to defend against every one right
because of course the attacker is only
going to do the weakest
link whatever one thing you didn't
defend against that's what the attacker
is gonna do and it won't matter that you
defend it against the other ninety nine
so you need to have a way to protect
these secrets that defends against
everything right attacks you've never
heard of and so that's probably not
going to happen by default it's gonna
happen because somebody has spent you
know careers and teams working on just
that problem and so that's what a secure
element does right the whole point of
using a secure element like this is that
that's all we do every day
just think about how the bad guys are
gonna try and get the secrets out we
don't know anything about temperature
sensors really all we know about is that
bad guys are gonna try and get the
secret out of our chip we don't want to
let that happen
okay so let's kind of build that up now
into an IOT thing yeah so this is sort
of how IOT devices look right right
you've got some application your IP the
thing that makes your device special
it's some sort of cloud connectivity
snack stack ideally connectivity to
Google cloud right because everybody
wants the cloud I mean without the cloud
how are you gonna get to your device
what good is it you've got some sort of
operating system maybe it's a real-time
operating system maybe not you got some
big processing element that's running
your communication stack and your
security stack in this case some you
know looking at something like tcp/ip
and TLS that's their common things there
are other ways to do it and then you got
some radio some wireless hardware and
some sensors to do your thing it's kind
of how things that's that's an IOT
device looks right that's how it's done
but you know let's think about it for a
minute you know in the world there's a
big variety of architectures and cost
points and power points for embedded
systems yeah you got everybody's holding
up the red one in the top right you got
some big multi-core processor with
gigabytes and fancy OSS and that's great
there's a place at a time for that I
wouldn't want anything less in my pocket
but that might not be the right answer
for the temperature sensor in room 23
maybe you want something a little bit
lower cost so so you could think about
something in the middle some kind of our
toss sort of thing maybe a little bit
more restricted operating system maybe a
real-time operating system it's a good
thing millions of those units are sold a
year but you know you you really like
zell 10 slide about that 8.4 billion and
that curve you know how you you want to
be on the billions asides right you want
to sell billions of devices if you're
gonna do that and if you're going to
consume that data right if you're gonna
think about how do I manage the heating
and cooling in a building with a
thousand rooms I need a thousand
temperature sensors right if I want to
manage some kind of a factory with a
thousand valves I need to know each one
of those vows I need to control them
right so now we want to think about
these billions of units where you want a
power room with 8-bit processors and so
AVR and picmicro processors are probably
the kind of processors you you were
gonna use they're the number1 and
number2 processors in the market but
these are very resource constrained
things there's not don't think gigabytes
of memory think K bytes in memory and
don't think you know how many how big is
the power supply gonna be think can I
make that battery last for five years
without replacing it right so so we're
talking about a totally different
environment here and this is the thing
that drives that 8.4 billion number
right it's this constrained environment
so how do I simplify the development of
an IOT device so that I can build those
small devices and I can get them to
market in a timely manner because the
other guys trying to build the same
thing right if I don't get there sooner
he's gonna take my market so so let's
redraw that picture a little bit
differently you still got your
application software whatever makes you
special you're still going to do that
you've got some kind of cloud
connectivity stacks but now let's let's
reduce that to the component pieces
necessary to talk to a stack here's the
component pieces for Google Cloud and
beyond that now we're gonna really start
to change things we're gonna say okay I
want to develop an environment where I
can automatically generate the drivers I
need alright because really I only care
about the stuff in yellow or orange or
whatever that color is up there I'm
gonna care about what's my IP I want to
push the button one click and get all
the other stuff done
and at the lowest level I want to split
the security and communication stacks
away from my processor I want to focus
on writing the software in my processor
my MCU that does what's important to me
processes that temperature right what's
the numbers it's not that complicated in
a sense and I'm gonna leave the security
stack I'm gonna put it in a secure
element I'm gonna take the connectivity
stack and I'm gonna put it in a wireless
element and now I'm gonna build a much
simpler and more secure IOT element and
I'm gonna get to market faster because
I'm gonna do it with much less software
and in a development environment where I
can push a button and get it done right
and that's what we're all about
so you know just so you don't think this
is vaporware ever it's a good concept
but if we can't reduce it to practice
then that's not so interesting so
Lucio's going to show a demonstration
later where we connect these four things
the the demonstration happens to use
this particular AVR microcontroller but
this concept this architecture this
software works with any one of the
thousands of microcontrollers that we
and other people sell what we offer is a
one-click software development approach
so doesn't matter which of the
processors you use you push that button
you get the software stack necessary to
do it the secure element that we've been
talking about here implements all the
algorithms whether it's symmetric
whether it's asymmetric to do that
cryptography secure that key and to
isolate your software stack from all the
cryptography so for instance I talked
about secure boot validating your code
image well that secure element can
validate the signature so instead of you
I haven't thousands of bytes and maybe
minutes of code execution time now you
pushed that hard stuff off to the crypto
processor it does that software stack
same for Wi-Fi this particular picture
shows a Wi-Fi chip
we got solutions with other networks as
well the one we're showing here despite
the congested Wi-Fi environment is the
wink 15 10 it's got the TLS and tcp/ip
stacks built in so you have to think
about that in your application right
think about it as a UART send some bytes
get some bytes
and it all would be useless if there was
nobody to talk to so it's all set up in
the same way to talk to Google iot-cloud
and so so now you've got this easy to
design solution with it easy to use
cloud environment and that's exactly
what your customers are looking for and
it's highly secure so when you go down
and attack it you're not going to get
that private key so let me pass off
there's all Tim thanks Carrie so just to
reiterate there are two sides of
providing a highly secure end-to-end
deployment a security and the cloud so
let's talk a little bit about the cloud
side of things so freaky challenges we
kept in mind why building an IOT
solution and while developing cloud IOT
secure device connection probably
needless to talk more about this that's
the topic of the presentation scaling on
demand meaning you start with the
prototype you deploy ten twenty hundred
devices and when you feel like it's time
you can easily go to a million an
actionable insight so these devices
generate lots of data and you have to
look behind that data what behind that
data what what kind of analytics you get
can get out of that data what you read
out of that data and so these are the
principles we kept in mind while
designing Google Cloud IOT so this is
just an overview of a cloud IOT core and
the whole ecosystem around it cloud IOT
core is our solution for connecting
devices managing them in ingesting
device data and sending configuration
and device updates to them so you can
see our edge solution here we just
announced it I'm not going to talk about
it we don't have time for that but
please check it out online it's really
cool so what you can see here is we have
these edge device we have these end
devices and then our edge solution and
then the cloud side of things cloud IOT
core
it's directly integrated with pop sub
our solution to general messages into
our cloud service other cloud services
so like loud functions or data flow and
then to store them in a one of our
storage solutions or visualize them
using data lab or data studio the
network very important to talk about one
of our strengths is our network when it
comes to an IOT deployment latency is
crucial so Google is actually the only
non isp company owning submarine fiber
and this network that we own enables us
to provide super low latencies and and
you get this out of the box if you start
using cloud IOT core just a little bit
more details about cloud IOT core there
are two main components protocol bridge
MQTT and the HTTP bridges that's where
devices connect that's where they can
send data and and receive configurations
or or commands it's super scalable and
and it's directly connected to pop sub
and and and of course the scale like the
scaling is automatic the device manager
is for managing the devices managing
configurations access control and there
is a nice UI as well for for managing
your devices but also API support is
available so security let's talk about
the authentication because this is
really unique in our solution so we are
using a jot based authentication the
device has the private key it's signs
the a jot token using its private key
and overloads the password field of the
MQTT Connect message with this shot
token so essentially what happens is
that we are providing a mutual
authentication without the well-known
TLS mutual authentication protocol now
of course this requires the public key
corresponding public key to be
registered in the cloud so that has to
happen before the device can
authenticate itself with the cloud and
so once again this is unique because you
essentially get TLS mutual
authentication functionality without
having to have the full TLS stack on
your device so that can save resources
on your devices which is a usual problem
in case of resource constrained devices
all right so let's take a look at well
the basic provisioning flow how you
register devices so the provisioner
whoever the provisioner is creates a
keeper stores the private key at any
device and then registers the public key
together with the device ID in the cloud
and then the device can connect by
signing a jot using its private key to
the cloud now this looks simple and good
but this is not the most secure solution
and that's because the key pairs are
generated using software and we just
discussed that using a secure chip is a
more like a highly secure solution a
more secure solution so this is how the
flow looks like using the secure chip so
the difference is really that that the
secure chip is added to your device it
already contains the public keys and
whoever is the OEM is whoever
manufactures the devices receives the
public keys as a file and can run a
script to register these devices and
then it's the same process when it comes
to connect when it comes to the
connection of devices now this is highly
secured secure it's simple it all looks
good but is this enough no so there are
still challenges here so there are two
main area of challenges one is key
management how do you secure the private
keys in case you do not use a secure
chip because not everyone
using a secure chip but even if you use
a secure chip how do you transfer the
public keys from the secure element
provider like microchip to the OEM to
the device manufacturer the other big
area of challenges challenges is device
management how do you map the public
keys to projects or registries so how do
you like define the location of your
device in your in your cloud project and
and these decisions have to be made at
the time of manufacturing so overall
it's a complex project and to tackle
these two problem spaces we are happy to
introduce cloud IOT provisioning a new
service available as an early as part of
an early access program so you can apply
for it and it's essentially an interface
connecting secure element providers and
device manufacturers OEMs so secure
element providers can upload public key
data into the cloud directly and these
these these public key this public key
data together with the corresponding
secure element ID is available for the
device manufacturers so device
manufacturers can create and assign
targets for these secure elements and
probably most importantly it provides a
way to to create generic devices devices
which for which you don't need to set
the target information the project
registry information at the time of
manufacturing they can download this
configuration as part of the first boot
so let's see a demonstration of this
all right this is the cloud IOT
provisioning early version interface as
I mentioned there are two personas here
the SE manufacturer so secure element
provider and the OEM and in this case
the secure element data is already
uploaded so I'm going to use this as an
OEM as a device manufacturer I'm going
to claim elements based on Real ID so
real is a set of these secure chips and
I already have a an ID prepared here so
I have claimed these elements so you can
see that these secured chips are now
listed and I can assign them to a target
but before I do that let me open the
console here so this is a cloud IOT core
I have if all goes well I have a
registry prepared here and you can see
that there is only one device in it okay
this one now I go back to the
provisioning service and I'm going to
assign these devices these secure
element two to a target what is the
target the target is essentially a
project ID region and the registry ID I
have one prepared here so let's do it
alright
what happened is that I have added these
devices to the project and we can see
the devices are here so one part that I
didn't demonstrate is that as I
mentioned these devices can download
their configuration as part of the first
boot I'm I cannot demonstrate that right
now but that's also part of the solution
whoo so with that I would like to invite
Lucho to the stage who is going to show
us another demo Thank You Zoe so I hope
you can hear me lucha de Accio I work
for microchip technology and I have to
say I love software don't get me wrong
but I like when software really starts
touching hardware and then the fun
begins for me so I'm here and since we
are at Google next I do the Google thing
which is I'm gonna show you something
new it's gonna be a sneak peek into a
product the microchip is preparing for
this fall and you get the privilege
actually to see it in action so it's
gonna be a live demo in front of you so
this is a concept that we've been
working on to demonstrate practically
the things that Zoli and Kari have been
describing in the presentation before
and so I'm gonna literally actually show
you a little board that is here is that
the thing it's one inch by two and a
half or so and and this is a concept
that we came up with to try and
demonstrate practically the
effectiveness of a secure element and
how actually ideal the Google cloud
solution that the use of the jot is for
bringing cloud solutions secure cloud
solutions even to the smallest devices
in the in the pyramid of the embedded
control world
right so we want to take a secure
solution to the cloud down to an 8-bit
device so I'll show you maybe you can
actually see it on the screen better
it's um it's quite small so I hope you
can figure it out I'll use a pointer
here and you'll see there's a debugger
area this is a full development system
if you want inside an engagement board
and this is a complete system here you
have the the smart of the solution this
is a small microcontroller just an 8-bit
you know as Kari said microchip makes
ships to billion units of this chips
every year this is not a cumulative
number every year we ship 2 billion of
them and this is what you know most bare
metal embedded control solutions are
made about there in the industrial and
automotive in all the fields so this
small 8-bit micro now is connected to
the secure element and I'm sorry Kerry
your slide had the secure element as big
as my chip but it's actually it is the
smallest thing on this board the secure
element is smaller than a temperature
sensor actually speaking of room 12 was
it 12 so 23 so so this is this is a
temperature sensor this is a secure
element with all the crypto elliptic
curve secure key management and all the
features built in there and this is a
light sensor for example that we added
here and also here you see a typical
radio module this is the wink 15 10 it's
one of microchip many wireless solutions
so all this connected on this board and
and I want you to notice also this
connector here there's this pin here and
this is where you can actually plug in
this is a microbus so you can choose
pick and choose between four hundred and
fifty additional sensors readily you
know off the menu
literally and and pick and choose and
try to quickly prototype whatever your
solution is so maybe it's not just a
temperature sensing room 12 maybe
there's also a humidity sensor and
pressure sensor and a altimeter and
whatever you want so so I will actually
demonstrate how this board works making
it
act quickly to the to the Google cloud
and so we designed not only just a board
you know that's easy that comes fast we
design a complete experience around this
on how we can get a user quickly engaged
with the Google cloud and so what I will
do now is I will actually power up this
board and that should blink some LEDs
that's what you expect huh is that
pretty I blink this for LEDs yeah that's
what we do and in better control we
blink a lot of LEDs and so so one thing
you might you might want to know is that
sorry and this is the good part of and
doing the live demo right so it's so in
the experience what you will see now is
that the thing that this board actually
behaves as a hard drive so my PC without
installing anything recognizes this as
if it was a flash stick basically there
is really no storage on the device and
so if I can change to two carries
desktop and if you can actually
visualize that on the screen thank you
so you will see that this this board
appears on a zoli's laptop as a hard
drive called curiosity
so hopefully will pick your curiosity
and and you will want to check inside
this this drive and inside this drive
again I didn't install any software
I don't need special drivers for this
you will see there is a bunch of
interesting files they're not real files
one of them is called click me so I hope
you will you will be tempted to press on
the click me one and and from there you
will actually see that by default
because it was a dot HTM file whatever
operating system you have a Mac a PC or
even a Linux box you will see it
immediately open the default browser and
the browser will open up on the page
that is a special landing page that we
prepared a sandbox and it's part of a
sandbox account but it it's this landing
page contains the real experience and
has been
prepared for us by by Google and
actually in particular by leverage a
partner that has been working with us
and with Google to create this ideal
experience so as you can see actually
you can see that the device in
particular the secure element and this
is the unique identifier of that secure
element and so we landed now on this
page this is a dynamic page and as lock
once I'll show you now how this this
page actually changes when when we do
connect to to the cloud and I have my
so
this is quite a hard test because we
tested this obviously in the room
without all of you with your phones on
the Wi-Fi hotspot' said present so there
is a hundred and twenty more than when
we tested this first hopefully I will
get it to to actually connect to the
right hotspot and I get to show you you
some some real data streaming on the
board and now it's not today so in the
last minute tough luck I think we have
to call it a day so so ideally basically
you would see the blue LED connect
directly to the to the correct hotspot
that is actually sitting here and and
then a green LED turning on as soon as
the connection with Wi-Fi is established
then a connection to the MQTT broker of
Google will happen immediately and then
after that you will see the board
immediately blinking a yellow LED thus
the sequence of color is if you notice
is the Google color sequence and and
then the yellow LED actually represents
each packet of data that is being
published to the MQTT broker and then
when that successfully happens as we
will not have the luck to see today you
will actually see on mice on your
screens on your browser you will see the
blue line connecting all the way through
and the page actually dynamically
instantaneously will show you the graph
with the two sensors data so the
temperature and the light sensor on this
board and it will be immediately
animated on your screen now good would
this be if if it was just a board and
just this part of the experience you
know the goal here is not only to give
you a five or sub thirty seconds that's
what we claim experience and connection
to the Google cloud but after that you
will want to change the sensors and
apply your own specific sensors so so
you will want to write your own firmware
inside the board inside the
microcontroller on this board and and
just for you if you're not familiar with
this particular brand of products you
might have heard you know
the AVR that is the microcontroller
shown here is the one that is inside the
Arduinos so most students today coming
out of schools and university and out of
the the hobbyist community are very
familiar with that and so they will want
to play with it and so professional and
non-professional developers actually
will find a solution that we prepared
for them which is as Carrie mentioned
before we have a rapid development
toolset that is composed of two the two
pieces of software MCC and and start or
one for the Picts devices and one for
the AVR devices and with those literally
with a click of the mouse
you will be able to see the image scroll
to the to the correct page so this is
start for the AVR devices and here you
see the blocks composing the project
that is actually running on this board
in this very moment and with this is
available in your browser so you will do
all your reconfiguration of the device
on-the-fly
clicking on each block changing the
configuration you see the crypto
authentication block that's what
controls the ECC 608 so all the software
is wrapped in there and templated by
that and so the mqtt are your key block
that you see there in blue is the block
that wraps the entire communication
infrastructure everything that is needed
to access the wink device the Wi-Fi chip
and and the part on the left where you
see scheduler ADC user the embedded
developers among of you will recognize
those names those are the acronyms or
the individual peripherals inside the
chip and so again you can go there and
configure them and select them and make
them read temperature humidity rate
whatever other entity you want to read
and so you can create a complete
solution with a few clicks of your mouse
and then heat up their export project
and just hit the build button on your
IDE and with this I will give back the
mic to Holly yeah and please stay on
stage just very quickly because we are
running out of time can we please go
back to the presentation
yeah thank you so just a very quick
summary of the whole presentation so as
I said there are two sides of the
end-to-end security providing end-to-end
security hardware software cloud strong
IOT security use a secured chip and then
ease of design with a turnkey MCU so
you've seen that 8-bit MCU which is a
brand-new and then when it comes to the
cloud simple connection which we were
unfortunately unable to demonstrate but
it is simple believe me I saw it and and
built-in connect so I mean built in into
these devices they can connect to the
cloud and scale so cloud IOT provides
scaling on the event and and also
actionable insights using the other
cloud other Google cloud tools and
services and with that we would like to
conclude our presentation thanks for
attending thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
you